متى تتمررون في رمضان قبل الافطار بعد
الافطار ام لا تتمرنون اصلا
قبل الافطار هو انسب وقت قبل سمعت في
اليوتيوب اتمرن قبل الافطار بساعه برافو
هاي معلومه صحيحه فعلا في تمرين قبل
الافطار راح يزيد من معدل الحرق لكن تمرين
الشديد والمرهق قد يسبب ازمات اخرى يعني
انت تعرف المزيد من الدهون ولكن تخسر
اشياء ثانيه على مستوى الكتله العضليه
وحجم العضلات التمرين قبل الفطور ممكن
يسبب لك جفاف ارهاق او ممكن لا سمح الله
اصابه رياضيه بعد الافطار التراويح اكيد
بعض الواحد يفطم ما نتمرن الا بعد فطور
بعد الفطور يعني الفريق اللي يتدرب بعد
الافطار لابد انك تتدرب بعد من ساعتين
لثلاث ساعات من تناولك الى وجبه الافطار
هذه اهم معلومه عشان تكسب اكثر على مستوى
الصحي وحتى على المستوى البدني
قبل رمضان ورمضان ما راح اتمرن انا لا ما
في خارج الشحن خارج التقطيع
بيموت ابدا
لا تتوقعوا ولا تحلم ولا تتخيل تكون جيد
في جوانب الحياه المختلفه دون امتلاكك
للصحه جيده وجسم قوي نصيحتي لكم نسمع عن
عاده 21 يوم انا بحكي لكم عاده الثلاثين
يوم واترك فكره انك تكون انسان صحي بدون
رياضه هذا وهم وهذا لا يحدث ابدا كل عام
وانتم بخير سلام